i don't believe i've ever spoken to this
man or interviewed this man and he holds
a a a position in my old hometown that
so many people are excited about and
counting on him to return
uh the great big blue
new york giants franchise to the top of
the podium and he is the new head coach
of the new york giants brian dabo how
are you brian
good rich how are you thank you for
having me on thanks for coming on uh uh
my pleasure all right so i i promised my
audience i would start this way and i
will uh all right uh you have to turn
daniel jones into josh allen go
go
you start
yeah
we're not gonna we're not gonna we're
not gonna do that um right we're just
gonna we're gonna work with daniel i
think that's unfair to
you know obviously i just left josh and
i'm coming here and daniel's his own guy
josh is his own guy you know we have a
long way to go we gotta build a
relationship and identify the things we
need to do to help daniel
which look there's a lot of things we
can do particularly on the offensive
side of the ball
and we need to be better at so it'll be
a long process but uh excited to work
with daniel obviously i'm i i place my
tongue firmly in cheek in our first
question and i apologize for that i
don't usually don't do that with
somebody but i guess it's not it's no
it's it's definitely you know you're
you're in the new york market and i i'm
assuming that you you've heard questions
in different ways to actually shape that
and so um what what what physical
attributes does daniel jones have that
you can bring the system in which josh
allen thrived and and get him to have uh
results that are extremely positive for
the giants what about that i thought
daniel did a good job as rookie year and
look he's had some injuries and again
he's had some different play callers and
different head coaches and you know
that's through no fault of his own
that's again josh's situation is a
little bit different it was it was you
know stability from the general manager
the head coach you know he and i worked
together from his rookie year all the
way until you know this last past season
so again there's a lot of variables that
go in that and in terms of helping a
player improve you know hearing the same
voice the same system speaking the same
language those are all things that that
daniel hasn't had yet so we got a long
way to go with him but we're going to
try to do everything we can to you know
put a system together that suits him you
know he's a big strong guy
has some athletic ability but we're ways
off uh from that all right brian dabal
here on the rich eisen show let's uh get
into um your career
um sure so you were a graduate assistant
way back in the day
with nick saban at michigan state how
did you first wind up on his radar
screen way back in the day
yeah i sent a lot of letters out
you know a couple of coaches guy by the
name of chris kosh ended up returning my
call brought me in for an interview
i left i was at william and mary at that
time went to michigan state for for two
years
uh worked for nick and and that staff
and then
ended up going to uh the new england
patriots in 2000 when uh coach sagan
went down to lsu uh so that was my first
year in the nfl was 2000 with with bill
and uh started out on the defensive side
of the ball
yeah and there was a certain uh retiree
that had just been drafted correct brian
back in that day oh yeah yeah he was you
know i was at michigan state uh
and he was at michigan
and we you know we've you know i just
you know got a great appreciation for
tom and you know got a really good
relationship with him and
i just uh you know obviously the best
that's ever played but also a great
human being um
you know we go back and forth we're
roughly the same age i was a couple
years older than him but you know coming
from the big ten and you know sparty
land and he was over there at the other
school
no offense rich
yeah okay
all right
we ended up we ended up beating michigan
that year the last year as a ga
but you know it was him and henson back
and forth you know that whole year i do
remember and i remember we we started
out we got fast they went down and then
they ended up putting you know henson in
and then bringing tom back in and tom
almost led him to an unbelievable
comeback victory uh much like he did i
think it was against alabama 38 35 or
something like that in the orange bowl
i'm not mistaken it's correct against
alabama who you know you eventually uh
returned to saban staff back then uh
later on in your career brian davil and
and it was you know a lot of the fire
that brady got built up in him at
michigan is part of the reason why you
know there are rings on on fingers for
for so many people and also the defense
the offense put it all together with
belichick uh orchestrating it at the
time is there anything from the saban
years michigan state alabama and
obviously uh new england that rests
within you and what could that be what
can giants fans know that comes with
your package from two of the all-time
great coaches at their levels as well
yeah i could spend i could spend a long
time talking about both those guys and
the influence they had on me just
extremely detailed
great leaders you know understand how to
build a team and and lead a team
very very smart in terms of situational
football can coach all the positions
but you know at the end of the day
you know you you take a step back and
you watch those guys you know the
leadership really stands out and of how
they you know organize a team
build a team lead a team unite a team um
just they're just you know wealth and
wealth and knowledge here from both of
those guys what about the demanding of
others what about that because sometimes
you know
you know no i know that but that's
usually every
huh that's usually sometimes an issue
though as a new hc comes in and and puts
in a system from
you know somebody and then it demands
something of others that uh you know uh
sometimes it's difficult to to command
that right from the get-go what do you
what do you think of that i think that
and that's a good point rich you know to
me i'm going to come in and be myself i
can learn from a variety of people which
i have i've been doing this for almost
25 years or
21 years in the national football league
and have worked from some very good
people and the thing you learn as the
years go by is
you just better be authentic and be
yourself and for me it's about building
relationships with the players
the coaches the support staff
and earning their trust with who i am
and once you're in your trust you know
then the respect comes in and once the
respect comes in then there's
accountability so you know that's that's
what i'm going to try to do it's not
going to be perfect i understand that
but at the end of the day i'm going to
try to be myself of course you're going
to use lessons that you've learned along
the way
but i think it's really important to be
who you are well i mean and in terms of
that coach brian abel new head coach of
the new york giants a few more minutes
left with him here on the rich eisen
show there was a um an article that was
written i think a few months ago talking
about a moment inside the locker room
with you and the entire staff and
members of the buffalo bills about
making everybody sit down if they had
been let go somewhere or fired somewhere
um and um the only person or cut or or
released the only person left standing
in the room was josh allen and then you
asked him uh what what did you ask him
again after he was left standing how
many scholarship offers he had you know
we were the only team
uh last year if i'm not mistaken or one
of the only teams
that had no first round draft picks on
offense other than the quarterback
uh not an offensive line spot not at the
receiver spot and look there's
expectations every year certainly we had
them from the previous year
but i think it's important to remember
where you come from and you know when
you're not selected in the first round
or you haven't been fired you know
there's sometimes there's there's not a
lot of obstacles that are in front of
you and i think all the guys in that
room
had to deal with some obstacle adversity
along the way and and how you deal with
those things
makes you better
you can let it eat you up and worry
about it and let it affect you
or you can you know grab hold of it and
say yeah and i've been through some
adverse times i've had times where i
haven't been at my best or i wasn't
picked or you know i was traded or cut
or fired as a coach and learn from those
experiences and and hit them head on and
again when you only have one person in
the room standing
um
that wasn't fired or hadn't been cut or
wasn't picked in the first round and
that person you know wasn't highly
recruited you know looking at his stats
in high school and had to go to juco and
then had to go to wyoming that was the
only spot he could good and then there
was in all this debate about whether he
should have been picked or shouldn't
have been picked or he's inaccurate or
he's this
i think that if you remember where you
come from that you that's a little bit
of fuel and in terms of remember where
you come from uh is that why you drove
yourself to the job i saw that is it
true that you drive from buffalo all the
way down to new jersey yeah i did you
know that's not a bad ride and you get
you get to make some phone calls look
you learn when
when you get an out well i've learned
and get an opportunity to to do this
which is a dream of mine
there's a lot of phone calls you gotta
return and i've tried to return you know
every text and every phone call that
i've gotten just because
i've been in that situation before where
you're either looking for a job or
you're trying to introduce yourself to
somebody and i just think it's important
to be a good person and
there's a lot of phone calls made during
that you know five and a half or six
hour drive whatever was a little bit
longer because of some of the snow yeah
i bet so you weren't listening to the
radio music what do you do i mean your
podcast
i think the entire ride was was phone
calls you know maybe i threw a biggie
song on there once
okay very good a little hypnotized okay
very good all right coach coach we like
it i like it everybody here likes it um
so
so uh and and so who did you call i mean
who who from your your life that you'd
be willing to share once you finally did
get this job i mean outside of your
family would you call yeah well you know
i didn't have i lost my grandparents
this year which were instrumental um in
my upbringing you know i didn't have a
father
i had a teenage mother when i was born
unfortunately they brought us into the
house and they passed away
you know kind of back to back here in
the middle of the season not necessarily
right at uh you know just kind of sorry
there's something
it's all right stuff going on here all
right apologize guys no it's okay
yeah so i don't have you know i called
my mom and talked to her for a little
while and
uh obviously talked to my wife but a lot
of the phone calls were made to you know
coaches and
scouts and people just reaching out
saying congratulations um you know just
try to hit those guys back all right
last one for you coach now that you are
a head coach in the nfl and um you know
there's a little bit more influence that
comes with that certainly uh when one of
the gentlemen writing your checks
is somebody who's so into role in the
nfl and is so deep involved in the nfl
his father's nickname is on the football
and he's very tight in the competition
committee world
would you tell john mara i think there
should be changes to the overtime rules
based on the way your tenure in buffalo
ended brian dabo what do you think yeah
i'll let those guys those guys figure it
out um
you know that's what do you think
obviously what do you think of that we'd
love to have another opportunity
here on the other side of it but
you gotta finish the job to try not to
get it into overtime but you know i'll
let those guys talk about that so you
have no opinion on the subject matter or
you do or yeah i have an opinion but
i'll keep that one to myself sorry rich
sorry
all right so i'll just have to get your
number and call you on your next
eight-hour road trip i'll see you at the
combine after you run your 40. okay
that's great you can fit me in i'll i
hope so i i would love to i'd love to
meet you i've heard
what are we going to run this year
well um
what are we looking at well brian asked
him if he started training yet
uh i i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
throw what he's stones are glad i'm not
i live in a glass house
whatever that statement is i'm not gonna
get into that thank you i appreciate
that whatever his training is it's out
it's much better than mine i'll tell you
that well here's the deal uh let's just
say the other michigan man that you may
have come across in brady's a little bit
more well conditioned at an advanced age
than i am but um i got to get on that tv
12 message i know i think i think maybe
i should do that that's not a bad idea
um so let's just put it this way uh my
best is five nine four i'm hoping to
beat that this year i'll bet you under
all right i appreciate that all all i
just want to do is just raise my much
money for st jude but uh yeah
you know all about uh you know charity
and making sure that uh that the right
stuff is taken care of that's part of
the reason why you're in the position
where you are and i appreciate the time
coach i really do yeah same here guys i
appreciate you having me on and uh let's
do that more today let's do this more
often let's do this more often can we
ask what his favorite biggie song is
though okay you want to do that coach
what is your favorite biggie song
hypnotized okay i got a lot of them
you know i got i got i got a lot of them
on uh
on him
maybe i should just kick in the door to
hype up your team a little bit kicking
the door kicking the door yeah kicking
the doors you she's good you know big
papa call them
there's a bunch of them baby baby okay
[Laughter]
you guys i think you should i think the
next break once you play a little biggie
look at him that's a head coach
producing rickshaw producing coach is
now putting me in a spot now richard
he's putting me in the spot yeah he also
has no idea he's talking to a die hard
cowboy fan so no but but i'd like him
right off the bat absolutely
look out
thanks coach thank you there you go
everybody what a total complete delay
oh my goodness
there you go everybody brian dabo's
liking biggie taking unders my kind of
guy
he's taking hunters let's go probably
able to go five super bowl rings man
five
yeah uh you're you're a cowboy fan and
hearing that is the new hc of the giants
looks like they've uh they've upgraded
it looks like they got a good guy there
huh i just don't look he's good with the
media
he knows how to he knows how to um
coach man yeah and he just won me over
with his favorite rapper so i mean he
also referred to the other schools
michigan i mean my god he's from canada
all right which is he's from canada and
he went to william and may you know he
his first coaching judge william and
mary two years with saban and east
lansing and he's still referring to
michigan like that yeah i saw a tweet
too
his first year in new england he was
paid fifteen thousand dollars and he
asked bill
how many hours a day am i going to work
and bill said well how many hours are in
the day
how about that man throw his truck down
this is exactly the type of guy that new
york is going to fall in love with if he
wins
oh my gosh